About two weeks ago Apple refreshed the 5K
iMac with new processors, graphics, ram, and
I called it the iMac Pro Killer!
Was I right?
Can this i9 iMac with Vega graphics compete
with a $5000 iMac Pro?
To give you a Spoiler, yea, and it's actually
faster in some ways.
We’ll be taking a look at Photos and video
editing, gaming performance, connections,
and more.
Check out the description for links to both
of these machines along with my personal suggestions.
Let's start out with prices.
If you spec these Macs as closely as possible
there's only a $750 difference, but the beauty
of the standard iMac’s is that you have
way more flexibility when ordering so if you
don’t need a 1TB SSD you’re not forced
to buy one.
You can also upgrade RAM yourself which can
save you up to $580, I’ll link to the ram
we used and our easy install guide down below.
If you’re comparing these two, you likely
need performance but are on a budget so we
think the configuration purchased makes the
most sense.
You have an 8 core CPU with Vega 48 graphics
and a price savings of around $1600.
On the exterior, the design is practically
the same, other than space gray color of the
Pro which to be honest looks really nice.
You also get matching peripherals with a full-size
keyboard.
The display are identical which isn’t a
bad thing.
The 5K resolution is still stunning and it's
quite bright with great color accuracy.
At the top, The webcam is better on the iMac
pro being 1080P instead of 720 and along with
that, the iMac Pro has more better speakers
as well.
Moving to the back we no longer have access
to RAM meaning can’t easily upgrade it yourself,
but because of that we have dual fan cooling
which may not make a huge difference with
8 cores but they are definitely needed if
you buy an 18 core model.
One thing that could make you purchase decision
for you is the IO.
The iMac Pro has double the Thunderbolt 3
ports and 10Gbe built in.
Not everyone needs these ports, in fact some
won't use them at all but for others two can
be limiting.
The only way to add 10Gbe to the standard
iMac is with a thunderbolt adapter, meaning
you could be left with just one port.
Along with that, the SD card slot supports
faster UHS-2 slots.
Both CPU’s have 8 cores and 16 threads,
but the clock speed on the i9 is higher, up
to 5Ghz instead of 4.2 which leads us to Geekbench
4’s CPU test where the 2019 iMac has a 25%
higher single core score.
This shows how it will perform with simple
single core tasks, so it could actually feel
more snappy day to day.
Looking at multi-core the i9 imac scores about
8% higher showing off its power when pushing
all cores.
In Cinebench R15 which is a rendering benchmark
that pushed the CPU’s to their Max the scores
are similar but the 2019 iMac still comes
out ahead.
These results are impressive to me, seeing
how this iMac with an unchanged single cooling
fan design is beating the iMac Pro.
But what about the graphics, clearly the Vega
56 in the iMac pro is a higher tier card than
the 48.
In Geekbench 4 the iMac Pro scores 20-25%
higher with Open CL and Metal tests.
You shouldn’t buy either one of these for
gaming, but say you want to have some fun
after the work is done.
We tested Unigine heavens extreme preset and
the iMac Pro had only about 5% higher FPS.
In real-world gaming, that a very small difference
and both of these can perform well with higher
setting under bootcamp 1440P resolution.
Check out our dedicated gaming video if you
want to see what performance you can get in
the real world.
Next, let's jump into photo editing, we tested
using Adobe’s Lightroom classic and both
machines perform very well as they should
you’re editing.
Import 50 RAW 42MP image the standard iMac
is slighly faster, Generation 1:1 preview
the iMac pro is a few seconds faster, and
exporting all edit 50 RAW photos to Jpegs
took basically the same time.
If you edit Photos, there’s practically
no difference.
Now let's jump into video editing.
Believe it or not, the standard 5K iMac was
13% faster.
If you edit standard 4K h.264 footage the
i9 iMac is an overall better value especially
in Premiere, but if you’re starting to work
with H.265 footage the iMac Pro jumps a ways
ahead because of it T2 Chip which the 2019
iMac doesn’t have.
As far as editing smoothness both are fantastic
overall.
The graphics cards seem to render stabilization
and effects very similarly in the real world
which is surprising.
This is a very difficult topic since the results
can vary so much based on your editing program
and even the files you work with so if you
what to know which one is faster for your
use case and why, check out detailed video
editing comparison after this video.
The iMac Pro is a really nice machine, I love
the color, the fact that it has more ports
and updated speakers, Its definitely the nicer
all in one, but its a very expensive machine.
Now that Apple went from offering at most
a 4 core i7 to a 5Ghz 8 core i9 and more powerful
graphics I feel that for most, the standard
iMac provides such a great value.
Unless you need the extra ports, the 2019
i9 iMac provides fantastic performance which
is actually better overall than the iMac pro
at a much lower price.
For most people, its the better choice.
Thank you guys for watching if you want to
see more videos like this one click this circle
above, and check out our detailed gaming and
video editing comparison right over here.